I mean Warsaw Poland visiting apart
enjoying it and the message in today's
little short video is learn to enjoy the
language don't be in a hurry learn
slowly in any case the brain learns
slowly you can't push it don't put
pressure on yourself don't think you're
going to learn the language in three
weeks or three months or even six months
enjoy the language like if you're
walking somewhere and you're not
concerned about when you're going to get
to your destination but you're con you
really just want to enjoy what you're
seeing as you walk along you're more
likely to enjoy and to take advantage of
what you have around you so and I said
today is learn slowly